today
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
enjoy over any organization or saying
stop the band in solidarity
[Applause]
women
[Applause]
[Applause]
the Latina because a mother and as the
granddaughter of immigrants I am here to
say we'll always need access to abortion
and we will never stop fighting to
protect preserve right
[Music]
No
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
most of the 7,000 workers will people
perceives and not in the States but
they'll do about 2300 we leave the
Detroit area they're trying to
restructure and resize their business so
they're more competitive they have a lot
of capital needs they have to pay for
autonomous and electric vehicle research
of their mobility in addition to the
millions of dollars that they normally
spend above taken from their normal
products all of that one's a big strain
on chemical dollars so they're trying to
small
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
family lives day by day
stop infringing upon my most fundamental
right to live in the pursuit of
happiness love and fight I stand here
and try to do all that I can but how do
I hate you the understand that my body
is mine not yours to pimp or not to
legislate regulate or to explore and
that revoking these rights will cause a
war the days ahead
we'll run threat the seed of oppression
darkness and Buddhists like cattle
robbery forcibly and the controller by
clerics will certainly these who are you
then you know taking away our privacy
and robbing us of intimacy while we're
using to acknowledge the legitimacy of
these hogs cows outlandish full and
grand Standish to please your maker in a
piece of Baker who sits in the highest
offices touting that we are the takers
all lives matter to you so these days
unless those lives are black brown or
gay such a segregated it may be a heat
but our voices we heard from need to see
we're not going back not now not ever
even with your hand on the lever will
keep fighting this fight here at floor
electric we will bring this house before
I'm riding his light if you do for my
child to witness sight judgment crease
where your vans and boxes systemic
oppression can't limit his my body or
expressive and because it's important to
get the impression that a post real
world
how free
question won't go back in these days nor
will we do what the Orangemen says
choices to make our bodies are temples
the geysers for fascism is not very
simple so here is a symbol of hope of
peace of resolution we don't
underestimate the power of our
[Applause]
so listen before I continue I want to
shout out everyone every org that is
here and it works with us on this okay
I'm gonna get my things down so don't
judge because I'm reading for the list I
don't want to forget anymore
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
that we would see in our lifetime but we
have and my friends we are gathered here
today with these great leaders like
Senator Blumenthal and senator patty
Murray and all these wonderful women in
the house
[Applause]
to announce right now two amazing
champions for women which will be
introduced later this week please help
me welcome congresswoman Judy Chu and
Senator Richard Blumenthal you'll need
the megaphone just stick that mic up at
your lips you just put the microphone up
at your lips I've had to be a man
standing for women's health care to
welcome the men who were here women's
health care rights are human rights to
the man of America let me say your stake
in this fight is as big as anyone that's
fight that's the bay dance do it war on
human health care and women's health
care imperiled all of our rights now I
[Applause]
worked in the building behind us war
justice Harry Blackmun
the Rope Robi way I worked for him the
year after he did it and we thought at
that time while this issue was over we
settled it right and here we are again
because there are filming groups and
individuals and states that want to defy
the United States Constitution are we
gonna let them do it
[Applause]
Judy Chu and I and her colleagues in the
house and Tammy Baldwin my colleague in
the Senate then Thursday are going to be
introducing a bill that says to the
States of America
you cannot restrict women's health care
[Music]
or any of those other suppose pretext
for restricting women's healthcare we
won't let you disguise these
anti-constitutional heifers protecting
women's healthcare when you mean to take
it away yes and to the men of America
let me say stand up for women's health
care and support
[Music]
these measures are not only morally
repugnant they are not only over the
cliff but they are meant to distract us
because we also have work to do on the
gradual erosion the chipping away the
slow motion overturning roev e way let's
not take our eye off the ball any
restriction on women's reproductive
rights is too much unconstitutional
morally repugnant unnecessary and Amaro
I'm proud to be here today and remember
all of the women and men who have laid
down their careers in dangers their
lives literally at clinics where
violence sometimes was detected where
physical coercion was sometimes used and
these new laws or everybody's evil
everybody's repugnant we are determined
to fight them are you a great champion
and a wonderful advocate representative
Judy Chu 5-part put the microphone right
up up at her lips please last week like
Alabama passed the most draconian laws
against abortion and you know what I say
to that stand up fight back
[Applause]
women's rights are under attack what do
we do that's right you know we cannot go
back to the days like that what once was
faced by my constituents have have told
me that in 1969 because she was pregnant
she got into an unmarked car outside the
airport in Mexico City because she was
unable to get an abortion in America she
was forced to take winds like this just
in the hopes of finding the doctors who
would perform an abortion she was 22
years old
alone and afraid well thankfully I
returned home but thanks to Roe versus
Wade we do not have to have pants facing
situations like this anymore but now we
have states like California Bama like
Georgia like Ohio that are going to lead
even more young women terrified about
their own bodies and their future why
are we
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's why I am so proud on Thursday to
be joining Senator Richard Blumenthal to
introduce a women's health protection
act along and my colleague Lois Franco
and Marsha and her senator Tammy Baldwin
this bill will stop these states from
passing these laws that chip away at our
constitutional right to abortion these
state laws which have been reducing the
size of of clinics and where physicians
can practice and it will finally put a
stop to this whack Amole so we have to
play against these states doing their
state based attacks against abortion and
that means no bans on abortions at six
weeks no requirements that clinic doors
be a certain width
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we have to and so once again when
women's rights are under attack what do
we do when women's rights are under
attack what do we do
[Applause]
all right horn
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
right now there were thousands of people
out of the city Chicago there was battle
sons of women around the country that
are all churches [ __ ] oh stop because
when we fight well thank you my brother
[Applause]
Senator Schumer all right I don't see up
so we're gonna keep it moving I am
really proud to announce a good friend
and Ally from alien voice the black
woman's reproductive justice
[Applause]
all right Georgia our partners park and
sister are taking down the doors of the
Georgia State Capitol
finding legislators that quote unquote
Murphy bans are unethical as you got
center our bodily autonomy
and Louisiana our partner women with a
vision over the Louisiana State Capitol
asked me to remind their legislators
they cannot they will not be silenced
[Applause]
and tomorrow they will partner with in
the fight Indiana take to the streets
and a pose of worship bands and stop
attack on reproductive justice country
block women women of color queer and
trans individuals lives on the line to
fight for the rights we know the worst
maternal mortality rates the highest
instances of voter suppression and over
troublesome health care outcomes for
black women are the same faith that wish
to eliminate our access to abortion care
[Applause]
women of color have been
disproportionately affected by laws that
were designed without our participation
and they clearly do not take our lived
realities and aspirations into account
apparently oppressive legislation like
the Hyde Amendment and those recent
abortion ban sent a clear message to
poor folk to women of color to transpose
that we have no power to control our own
reproduction under Roe T wave rights the
existence of the constitutional right
over our bodies and our health
how much we have to wait when black
women coins the term reproductive
justice 25 years ago craving our work to
dismantle reproductive oppression
reproductive oppression looks like
forced breeding of enslaved black women
it looks like forced sterilization of
women need to be reminded of my coercion
and lack of respect when we visit our
doctors and it looks like the backward
abortion bans that we're seeing right
now our lived experiences as well as the
experiences people Warren guide our
fight for freedom with their roadmap we
will win
[Applause]
[Applause]
get my grade up read lips
[Music]
right up your lips
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and we especially every single one of
you here today are what standing between
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
each woman actions of Hawaii
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so that pretty soon at this rate the
women in our country are going to wake
up and know that we no longer have
control over our body we have to undo
decades-long precedent of course while
we wait is one of them that is why we're
standing firmly
corset Cavanaugh are you a lift
[Applause]
[Music]
and I told them I was coming to a rally
and burn the Supreme Court and they said
why because we are we have the bite
force of worship right how many of you
think they are meant to be showing ah
swimming when and if you wanna have
babies Nona simple one of them raise
your hand
[Applause]
[Music]
they got it how many of you boys think
it's government to be telling girls and
women when and if we're gonna have
babies
[Applause]
[Applause]
worship rights from women by its lone
dissent in a case that should have been
covered by home women all the states so
many of them
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the women of the house are wearing white
and we have roses and purple ribbons
today is the 100th anniversary of women
getting the right to vote in this
country we will never be totally equal
until we have the right to full control
of our bodies that means we've got to
stop these restrictions on a woman's
right to an abortion every woman in
America should be outraged what's
goodbye what's going on right now in
fact every person in America should be
outraged by what's going on
we're standing here at the Supreme Court
because the Republicans and the right
wing in this country think they're going
to get the court to reverse Roe versus
Wade we won't let that happen every day
it's every way we must resist can you do
that
we have to stand up for our rights
right now the rights of every woman the
rights of every trans woman in this
[Applause]
you're heard I'm the co-chair of the
pro-choice caucus in this country for
the first time in our nation's history
we have a pro-choice majority in the
u.s. we have legislation representative
Presley and to all the representatives
who are here today we have legislation
to protect a woman's right to choose we
will pass it but we will only pass it
with your help can you do that this is a
key moment in our history
[Applause]
[Applause]
well we know what's happened those who
have planned to repeal role and take
away a woman's right to choose
think they can now win can they wind
from Alabama to Missouri to Texas and
beyond Republican legislators are waging
a war to unravel a woman's fundamental
rights they are responsible for 302 Lee
proposed restrictions we are here to
send these folks a message not on our
watch most Americans don't want to see
row overturned and they're doing a sneak
attack they say oh they don't like the
Alabama law and then they vote for
judges who will of all the Alabama law
and repeal row they are the kinds of
people they are this is the act of
hypocrisy here's what they say with one
hand they say oh no I don't like the
Alabama law with the other they say give
me judges that are for the Alabama law
and we'll learn to row is that hypocrisy
[Applause]
all the Republican senators who vote for
judges will repeal role and then say
they don't want to be s is what some of
the judges they voted for Judge Leonard
grass
he said roe v-- wade is morally bankrupt
judge Amy Cohn barren she said Roe was a
in erroneously decided the one they
voted for last week just about all of
them or every Republican she said
Planned Parenthood kills 150,000 women
and contraceptives cause cancer
and now they're gonna move Stephen Clark
who's affiliated with a group that
compared Rhoda Dred Scott they think he
should be a federal judge do we do we
take the Federal Society which is
dedicated to revealing Roe should pick
judges this is their game plan their
game plan is to load up the bench that's
why we're here at the Supreme Court with
people who wanna undo Roe repeal Roe
greatly curtailed Roe that's their game
plan but we are here to expose them we
are here to show America that America is
pro-choice who will not stand for
Republican senators who work to
undermine Roe I'm with you all the way
aren't the victory everybody
[Applause]
all right if you are outraged that 25
men in Alabama voted to take away
women's rights your own buddy
join me insane if you want to send a
message to the justices right up those
steps that Roe versus Wade is the law of
the land and they must uphold it say
stop the band reproductive health care
is health care that abortion care in
health care say stop the bands on Lena
what and I am the president of the plan
I am a doctor and my job is to take care
of women in this country and on behalf
of the one in five women in America who
have come to Planned Parenthood for care
I stand with our patients to D nails
these unprecedented unethical and
dangerous attacks on women's health and
rights and I think you're champions in
Congress for standing where that's ready
to fight here on the steps of the court
in the house and in the Senate but these
extreme bands are no coincidence
first Trump and pence filled the courts
with judges willing to give politicians
power and control over women's bodies
and we are looking at you Cavanaugh
second they started a misinformation
campaign manufacturing crises to cover
up for what they are really doing which
is third they passed extreme bans in
order to overturn Roe are we going to
stand for that because for their
dystopian plan to work there is one more
step they need us to be silent
women in this country will stay silent
while our our does anyone think that any
of us women men all people will stay
silent when they endanger our health and
strip us of our bodily autonomy so
here's our message to you President
Trump because we had enough of you all
you politicians so nothing about
people's bodies that yet you're making
decisions for patients about their
health and speak out because we know
you're keeping people unhealthy is a
tool of oppression
we will stand up and speak out because
you don't get to call yourself from life
where you are taking health care and
away from people and we will stand up
and speak out because we are Planned
Parenthood and we live with women and
touches who fight to protect everyone's
health and right
[Applause]
and to all your allies hear our voices
as we say we will never be silent
we will never back down in America
stands with Planned Parenthood
[Applause]
we'll fight now and all the way through
November 2020 to make sure that you
don't get to keep your job if you are
ready to take action today say stand up
speak out if you will always stand with
us to protect the right to safe legal
abortion care say stand up speak out
[Applause]
everything you have because this is the
fight